hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about a specific laboratory test
called the Snider test which uses Snyder
test augur to determine a person's
cavity susceptibility so first of all
let's think about what causes cavities
well a major cause of dental cavities
also known as dental caries our oral
bacteria as bacteria living in the mouth
that ferment dietary carbohydrates so
carbohydrates that you eat particularly
refined sugar producing an acid that
degrades tooth enamel so basically if
you're eating a lot of you know candy
drinking soda white bread a lot of that
kind of thing a lot of carbohydrates in
your diet that provides a food source
for the specific oral bacteria like
lactobacillus acidophilus instructor
caucus meats hands those are two of the
major ones certainly not the only ones
though that will ferment those sugars
producing an acid and the acid damages
your enamel on your teeth and so that
brings us to the Snyder test so a Snyder
test uses Snyder augur to measure a
person's cavity susceptibility and it
does this by taking an oral sample
basically saliva and measuring the
amount of acid produced by bacteria in
the saliva
over time this Snyder augur in
particular is known as a differential
medium
differential medium is one that visually
distinguishes bacteria based on
biochemical characteristics so basically
if you've got different types of
bacteria they have different kinds of
biochemical characteristics such as the
ability to ferment or not that can
result in changes that can be seen
visually something like a color change
for example and in particular with the
Snyder auger it has to do with the pH
and so the the auger itself starts at a
pH of about 4.7 and there is a pH
indicator in there called bromo crystal
green which is at this pH of when it's
out of pH of four point seven it is
green in color but when acid is produced
by these oral bacteria things like this
lactobacillus and streptococcus that
will lower the overall pH to four point
four and anything this four point four
or lower will cause that bromo crease
all green to be yellow
so with that in mind let's look at the
test procedure you started out with
Snyder auger his brain initially the
Snyder auger is composed of glucose
right Lucas well we said that it's
dietary carbohydrates that these
bacteria ferment and so glucose is the
carbohydrate that's used in this test
and then I already mentioned the Roma
kriesel green that changes colors based
on the pH it's our pH indicator and then
the Snyder auger also includes auger
that's just the solidifying agent in
other words that's what keeps the stuff
in the tube kind of this solid and gel
like consistency instead of a liquid and
so here's the procedure the person will
have approximately point one milliliter
of their saliva collected this is prior
to dental care
that means prior to brushing their teeth
or they wake up first thing in the
morning and they collect a saliva sample
before they brush their teeth or floss
torben any mouthwash to collect the
bacteria that's collected in biofilms
it's kind of grown up as a biofilm on
your teeth overnight so get at least
point one milliliters of the saliva and
knock you Layton melted Snyder auger
that's just because when you order the
Snyder auger it's typically solid so you
loosen the cap boil it for a while that
will melt it then you can add your 0.1
milliliters of saliva to it but the cap
back on kind of roll it in your hands to
make the saliva is mixed throughout that
melted liquid and then as it cools to
room temperature the audible Rees
solidifying you then incubate at 37
degrees in this body temperature for
three days some protocols call for four
days but I'll tell you why that doesn't
really matter
in a second then you need to interpret
the results and you do need to be
checking the tube every 24 hours so you
can't just let it sit for three days you
have to keep checking on it at 24 hours
48 hours 72 hours etc and so you
interpret the results based on this
table in this table wherever you see a
plus sign that means that the tube has
turned yellow wherever you see a minus
sign that means that the Snyder augur
has remained green and so of course
yellow means that the pH has fallen to
4.4 or below because of acid production
during fermentation by these oral
bacteria and if it's still green that
means they're happy there's not enough
of that bacteria in the oral saliva
sample to create enough acid to cause
the color change and so you just look
here if at 24 hours the tube is already
yellow meaning a positive sign that
means that the cavity susceptibility is
considered severe and I've seen this
with students before their saliva turns
yellow overnight and they have a severe
cavity susceptibility and typically
they've had a lot of cavities in their
lives if it's still green at 24 hours
but by 48 hours it's turned yellow
that's the moderate susceptibility if
it's still green at 48 hours but turns
yellow at 72 hours that's the slight
susceptibility if it is still green a 72
hours if after 3 days of incubation then
we can see that a negative cavity
susceptibility and that's because by 96
hours or just after 4 days of incubation
whether it's whether it's yellow or
green it's still really considered a
negative cavity susceptibility because
there were so few of these types of
bacteria in the oral sample so I want
you to think about a couple of things
here if your sample turns yellow you
know immediately or within 24 hours does
that mean that you are doomed
cavities no it doesn't because remember
that what causes the cavities is the
acid that is produced only when these
bacteria have a lot of dietary
carbohydrates to be fermenting so if
you're following a low carbohydrate diet
you're eating a few carbs limiting your
process you know refined sugars in
particular then even if you have the
bacteria in your mouth they're not
producing this acid that will cause the
dental cavities on the other hand just
because you have a slight or negative
susceptibility does not mean that your
diet doesn't matter because you likely
still have at least a few of these if
you start eating a lot of these refined
carbohydrates they are likely to
increase in amount in your mouth which
could lead to cavities later also
remember that it's possible to not have
very many of these in your mouth and
then to suddenly get more of them in
your mouth for example if you are eating
and drinking out there people are
kissing someone anything that would
result in a lot of saliva exchange over
time you could possibly get bacteria
from their mouth that then takes up
residence in your mouth and that then
does increase your susceptibility to
cavities so if you are interested in
this you can also see some videos I have
on other differential media for example
mannitol salt agar is one that's not a
differential medium that I have a video
on that you can check out if you are
interested thanks for watching biology
professor today and have a great day